a fateful meeting in the ancestral plain
and the dark Road of Revenge the New
Black Panther has some personal issues
to work out morning spoilers ahead while
it's a common complaint from some fans
that films don't stay true to the comics
the Marvel Cinematic Universe has still
managed to make things work power sets
may have changed and origin stories may
have altered but that doesn't stop the
worlds of Thunder gods and advanced
beings from the darkest depths of the
sea from crashing into hours and making
a space for themselves in the case of
black panther akanda forever though
there's one hero in particular that has
had a drastic change from their origin
story one that could provide a whole new
terrain for the first steps in a hero's
journey wakanda forever ended with only
one remaining member of the panther
tribe also it would seem before the
post-credits scene to Watch the Throne
heavy is the head that wears the crown
though and it becomes apparent that
shuri is veering away from the noble and
just way of ruling with fresh young eyes
looking forward to akanda's Future what
does it mean for wakanda and what kind
of dark territory could it take us to
when the Black Panther returns
in a phase that has seen heroic mantles
pass to others brave enough to take them
on sure he follows in the lines of a new
Captain America and the fleeting but
Mighty Thor this might have been a shock
for some but it's nothing new for fans
of the comics the films are inspired
from unlike in the original film comic
shuri had full intention of becoming the
first female black panther only to be
bested by her older brother t'challa in
2005. only during the story arc of dark
Reign after the King's life was
endangered that his sister take the
title of wakanda's protector until
t'challa was back to full health and
able to continue his previous duties
sadly this is not the case in Black
Panther wakanda forever following
t'challa's passing off screen as well as
Queen Ramona's death shuri accepts that
her home still needs its protector and
finally answers a call to follow in the
tradition she used to scoff at sure he
is for now the official Black Panther
and is a task that understandably takes
its toll culminating in a personal
Journey that turns a classic Hero true
rope on his head in a fascinating way
after taking her artificial heart-shaped
herb shuri's hopes had been greeted by
her mother or late brother for Council
are quashed when the air turns deathly
cold and none other than Eric killmonger
greets her with some harsh truths doing
so awakens a side of shuri we've never
seen before killmonger gives her the
answer she'd been fighting to accept and
the ramifications of what that looks
like if she acts on them she wants
retribution and here it is though she
only comes close to acting on it it's
clear that she still has an inner
turmoil that could Ripple out into
wakanda's future besides being a film
depicting the various forms of grief
black panther forever brilliantly
demonstrates the different views that
can lead to actions not everyone may
agree on shuri has always stood apart
from her family and wakanda's beliefs
and perspectives and here it becomes
even more apparent Defiance in Tradition
and willing to go against the rules if
necessary this new Queen is a far cry
from the playful princess we met back in
2018. interesting guess what I call them
sneakers these may be restored to both
worlds above and below the water but in
doing so it feels like shuri has gained
an edge that her brother lacked and
that's her cousin has succeeded in
igniting Vengeance has consumed us she
tells Neymar echoing her brother's own
words
has consumed you
don't letting it consume me t'challa
managed to temper his anger better than
his sister did and it makes us Wonder
while Sherry's bloodlust return should
another enemy cross wakanda's borders
could it cause an ease among the ranks
all of these questions if answered could
lead to a new more tense time in wakanda
and an unexpected era the Black Panther
will return but will it be one to be
welcomed or be wary of
[Music]
foreign